so the so the Jews and Christians have
the Torah and the gospel and if they
open up the Torah and the gospel they
will find Muhammad written in there
right right but here's the thing we
don't find them in there so the quran's
false yeah
that's all
right that's what
I all right those who follow the
messenger the prophet who can neither
read nor write
who they find written with them in the
Torah okay in the okay okay look what I
what I think that means is like because
we know that the in that the inil was
like revealed so what what that might
might mean is like it was written and
then God like revealed it or God
revealed it first and then it was
written then there's nothing to reveal
yes it was revealed first the gospel
message was revealed it was preached by
Jesus and then then people wrote it down
wait so the gospel the gospel has had
nothing in it and then it having
something at first it was an oral
message that Jesus walked around
preaching he was out preaching the
gospel okay and then people wrote down
what he preached wrote down what he did
wrote down what he said okay so so that
means that you can say Jesus revealed it
and like it was written written like
everything that Jesus revealed was
written yes absolutely abolutely yes so
that that makes it like something that
was revealed yes the gospel is a
revelation wait so what what were you in
him arguing about I don't get it well he
was trying to argue that the NG wasn't
written I have a question for you what
what what verse what what's the reason
like what's something in the Quran in
the Quran or or in the Hadith that makes
you like not believe in Islam the verse
I just showed you because it says it
says that we will find Muhammad written
in the Torah and the gospel we don't
find Muhammad in the Torah gospel so
Islam's false yeah but the thing is
Muslims don't believe that the that the
Torah and the Bible are preserved
correctly so I don't care what Muslims
believe the Quran says it is the Quran
says that it's with us that we have it
and that we can read it and that we
should judge by where does the Quran say
that it just it just you just read it it
says who they those who follow the
messenger the prophet who can neither
read or write whom they find written
with them so the Torah and the gospel
are with them they have it it's not
corrupted it's not lost they have it and
they're supposed to open it up and find
Muhammad in it so when they open it up
and we don't find Muhammad in it the
Quran is is false does it say have it or
yes it says it's with them look look
written with them wait wait start start
from on
to those who follow the messenger the
prophet who can neither read or write
yeah whom they find written with them in
the Torah and the inil the gospel you
know what it's it's it's it's so obvious
that this comment these commentators
halali and Khan these two Scholars they
even say it's talking about Deuteronomy
which is in my Bible and John the Gospel
of John wrote wait this is this is this
is theith or this is this is the Quran
this is Brother this is chapter seven
this is Surah Al oh this is the Quran
now just to be clear these these these
parts in the brackets these are not part
of the verse These are what the
commentator the translators is what they
put in the verse so the Quran doesn't
say John or whatever but I'm saying that
it's worth mentioning that these two
Scholars Islamic scholars translating in
the Quran they understand it to be
talking about the Bible we have today
okay what verse what verse was that
because I want to read it in Arabic this
is chapter 7 verse 157 157
7 verse
157 all right so all right so so this is
this is like when I contined the verse
it's saying like those those who who
follow the prophet and uh and they find
them find them written in the inil and
the Torah you're right about that but uh
like he should be in the inil and the
Torah yeah yeah later is saying uh in
the of the Torah he orders them
in uh to do good deeds and and uh
doesn't uh and like uh it's a sin to
like I don't know how to say it in
English but like to do like bad things
kind of okay yeah but like this is this
is what I'm trying to say it's like they
in Arabic it's not saying we have it
it's saying what is what is my homie
look do you know what in
Arabic that's those who
yeah yeah
those so it's not saying those who have
it those who find it written no no no no
no no bro what does what does uh mean
IND like uh where they are exactly so
it's with them it's where they are it's
with them so it says that the Torah and
the gospel they find written in with
them where they are
yeah written way written where they are
in the in the Torah and no it's with
them it's in the it's written in the
Torah and the gospel with them not not
with them it is with them what do you
mean that's the thing there's a
difference between when you read it in
Arabic and when you when you read it in
English I have it in the Arabic yeah
read in Arabic doesn't mean with them it
means where they are come on
brother let me let me let me take it
with what you're saying what does where
they are mean man like where they are
like so it means it means with them
right if if if I say if I say um you you
will find the book where they are does
that mean that the book is with them
with them yeah but with who who who is
them the people who have the Torah and
the gospel yeah who ha who has the Torah
and the gospel that's what I'm saying
the Jews the Jews and the Christians the
people who have the Torah and the gospel
already like played with it like that's
what we believe that's I know that's
what you believe the Quran never says
that the Quran no the Quran never says
that the Quran says that the Torah and
the gospel are with them it's where they
are and that the Quran is confirming
what they have yeah it's talking about
with the people who believed in the in
the like uh who it's not talking about
the people who believe it simply says
the Jews and the Christians have the
Torah and the gospel man it's not the
Christians it's not it's talking about
the the people who follow the the
messenger but people who follow the the
messenger Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam they are the ones who have the
who uh who like where they are they have
the Torah and Jew are they Muslims yes
okay but we don't know who who these
people are like so the Muslims guys have
the have the Torah and the gospel listen
listen you're not you're not this is bad
man the the Muslims have the Torah and
the gospel no the Muslims the people who
had the yeah the Muslims who had because
because the the Bible where something
sent from what we believe from God too
from like Allah yeah because we believe
that Allah sent the in the the in the
Torah those are things that we believe
in I know you I know you believe that
relax you're saying you just told me
that the people who have the Torah and
the gospel are Muslims they're the
Muslims who H who yeah the Jews and the
Christians don't have it the Muslims
have it huh we don't know when they when
they had it like that's what I'm saying
the people stop stop dude stop going off
other things focus on the thing that you
just said right I'm focused the Muslims
not the Jews not the Christians the
Muslims have the Torah and the gospel is
that what you're saying yes okay so so
the people who who receive the Quran
they are the ones that have the Torah
the gospel right yeah okay good all
right so let me let me read you
something let's see if let's see if this
works and see if this works now you're
lasting longer than the previous guy
because I like you but um
and I and I think that it is an honest
um it's an honest mistake that you're
making I don't think that you're being
purposely dumb but if I figure out that
you are you're about you'll be bounced
but okay so look it says but how do they
come to you this is chapter 5 verse 43
if you want to read it in the Arabic go
ahead and read hold on let me let me
pull it up before you start reading in
English Indo means in their possession
I'm getting text from an Arabic speaker
who's telling me this what verse 43 43
yeah 43 all right you can read it but
how do they come to you for decision
while they have the Torah in which the
plain decision of a is in yet even after
that they turn away for they are not
Believers so who are these people that
have the who are coming to Muhammad for
a judgment but Allah says why are they
comeing to you when they have the Torah
who are these people that have the Torah
that are still disbelievers probably the
Christians that were back then like had
the Torah but I thought the Muslims are
the ones yeah they had it no no that's
not what I mean but like like everybody
had like access to it I think they it
was just like given to the Muslims so so
did the Jews and the Christians also
have the Torah and the gospel I think so
I all right beautiful nice we can work
with that so the so the Jews and
Christians have the Torah and the gospel
and if they open up the Torah and the
gospel they will find Muhammad written
in there right right but here's the
thing we don't find them in there so the
quran's false yeah that's that's what
I that's what what I'm trying to tell
you is like we believe like every every
single Muslim that I know believes that
we don't have the Torah and we don't
have the in I know hey guess what I know
every every single Muslim that we talk
to disagrees with the Quran the Quran
says we have it Muslims say we don't
have it the Quran says that Muhammad is
in our Bible Muslims don't believe that
or actually some other Muslims actually
do believe that he's in our Bible as we
saw with the commentators here or other
Muslims that try to make the argument
Deuteronomy 18 the prophet like Moses uh
John 14 the comforter coming after Jesus
right there are Muslims that are songs
of Solomon like like you like you talked
about earlier how Muslims try to use
Song of Solomon oh wait that that might
be true then wait that means that means
Muhammad was in the songs of Solomon bro
but you want to know what's crazy is
that Song of Solomon is not the Torah
it's the Old Testament it's not the
Torah though yeah cuz we don't have the
Torah that's what you mean no we do have
the Torah Song of Solomon is not part of
the Torah the Torah the Torah are five
books Genesis Exodus Leviticus Numbers
and Deuteronomy they're the first five
books of the Old Testament that's what
the Torah is Song of Solomon is not not
a book you consider like the songs of
Solomon in thean say that again you
consider like the songs of Solomon is in
the in thean No Song of Solomon is a
poetic book it's one of the songs right
so you have in the Old Testament you
have a mixture of genre if you will you
have the Torah you have the prophets you
have the Minor Prophets Major Prophets
Minor Prophets and you also have the
poetry books like the Psalms Song of
Solomon you know uh books like
Ecclesiastes so the Old Testament
contains different genres of scripture
and song So Song of Solomon is in its
own category the Torah is a different
category than Song of Solomon I get it
all right man well you better you better
hope my granny don't find you bro man if
she wake up man I'm right here man I'm
waiting she she might be the one to get
me to say a should do she might be the
one I'm not I swear to God I swear to
God like I'm not even joking about this
I don't care like who you debated man
like all these all these people I
believe like she knows more than all of
them I swear to God then that's who I
want to talk to I don't I'm tired of
talking to these Chums man tired of
talking to
stop talking to these and Hamza and John
fontain and and manour Speakers Corner
and Hamza Den Muslim Cowboy D over D Ry
I'm tired of talking to these Chums
bring me the grandma man all right man I
got you bro but but don't get bro she
she might get mad so don't don't don't
talk back look I I know how Granny's are
no matter how it is I a you know I I
will never talk talk over a granny never
all right about thato about
that all right I'll catch you br I'll
see you all right bro nice talking to
you bye peace peace you gonna come back
again with another one